hey everybody it's mike from overflows
and welcome to this video that i'm
shooting on a question i got recently in
our weekly group training session for
users of my software was what to look
for in the order flow on a 10 minute
footprint chart and
you know this is a question you know
whether you use my software using you
know another company software
you probably are asking you know
mike you know i watch your videos and
you know i see you using range based
charts you know 30 second charts one
minute chart um tick charts volume
tracks but i'm i don't i'm more of a
swing trader or i have a longer time
frame that i'm looking at um you know
what should i look for
specifically on the footprint chart um
you know in a 10 minute chart now
whether you're using a 10-minute chart a
5-minute chart or a 15-minute chart you
know it this is going to apply this is
not
um strict for a 10-minute chart you know
anything
within the order flow can be applied on
a wide range of chart now do keep in
mind i'm a big believer in this that the
information that's derived from the
order flow is best used
as fast as possible you know as soon as
you get something that looks actionable
you know you should take action you
shouldn't wait for
you know the 10-minute bar to close
before you take it but again you know
it's it's a different style of trading
when you're on longer term charts as
opposed to you know a one-minute chart
so
that
leads us into the next point
you know are there certain things that
only appear on a 10-minute chart that
don't appear on you know say a
one-minute chart no you'd be looking at
the same things you know i've created
lots of different videos on sort of
different things to look for in the
order flow but when you start looking at
longer term charts i think it you can
narrow it down into what you're looking
for so let's take a look at
some charts here now
again you know everybody trades
different markets everybody trades um
you know different time frames and it's
it's hard to
really shoot a video that covers
everything all at once because that
would there's so many different
combinations and i'm going to start here
with this is a 10-year
10-minute chart now the nice thing about
10 years is you know they generally move
pretty slow and
you know honestly i can't
look at a
10-year
chart on a one minute uh basis because
it just moves so slow and you know i
find that using a range based chart or
you know at least a five minute chart on
a ten year is
much better so you know i'll use a
10-minute chart here then i'll take a
look at a couple other markets on on a
10-minute chart but
basically what i look for there's about
four things when i start looking at
longer term charts and
you know the first one now again you
know these aren't in any particular
order you know it's not like a checklist
where you start at one and go to two or
three four you know if any of these
things start appearing um
on the chart
then you know it gets my attention and i
go from there so the first one obviously
is is a basic one that we all know um
stacked imbalances and you know stacked
imbalances when you have
three or more imbalances stacked neatly
on top of each other you can see right
here there's a nice stacked imbalance
here on this 10-year chart right the one
against 1551 again sorry 127 against
1881 421 against 2051. right next bar
went up kept going continued um then
when sideways came back into that stack
buying a balance and took off now a lot
of times on 10 minute charts or
15-minute charts you're going to get a
stacked imbalance and the market's just
going to hold it's going to
come right back into it so for example
let's take a look at
an e-mini you know on when you start
getting into these other markets like
e-minis
uh you know during the cash session
what you're gonna get a lot of you're
gonna see like here this is a stacked
selling and balance and then the next
bar it just overlaps it quite nicely now
me personally i probably wouldn't look
at
using order flow on stock indices just
because you know it's kind of volatile
now that's just me that's not to say
that you can't use order flow on it but
you know honestly if you're trading
stock indices on a 10-minute chart you
have a much bigger
risk
tolerance you mean you should because
obviously the bars are going to be you
know they can be very big like you can
see this bar from 45 21
um you know all the way up to 42 so it's
you know a 20
20 point bar but stacked imbalances
right lots of times
unlike here in the 10 years right we see
it just
came came in and then market started
running up when sideways came back in
and started running up a lot of times on
um
you know some of these more
markets that have more volatility you're
going to see them overlapping right like
you see here
95 against 3 80 against 9
371 against 71 then the next bar opens
up trades around there goes a little bit
higher and then sells off okay
so
it's not that you see a stacked selling
imbalance and right away you got to get
short right let the market start going
in the direction of that imbalance
you know personally i like it when it
happens in the next bar but you sort of
had this bar in between
before the sell-off and again you know
when when i'm looking at a 10-minute
chart
i think you're best served trading it
during the cash hours
um you know here was this was on
monday the 4th right you've seen a
couple bars in here stacked by and
balance
stack buying and balance but then it
just went sideways right it couldn't go
any higher eventually started going
higher as you can see here but think
about it for a second right when you're
on a 10 minute chart as opposed to
a one-minute chart
how many do you think you get a lot more
imbalances no
okay and the the sad thing is
if you're trading a
you know a one minute chart
you're gonna you know this bar is
probably going to be just this part
right here so you got this nice
actionable stacked buying imbalance that
you can trade off of
but by the time the bar you know it's a
10 minute bar so it's got to close at
after 10 minutes right so you're waiting
10 minutes for this bar to close and it
had this nice you know move from
basically you know 46 all the way up to
57 a nice 10 point move right after that
stacked buying imbalance
that you're probably missing out on
because you're
trading in a 10 minute bar i mean that's
my argument whether or not you agree
with it you know is is up to you but
you'll notice how the market did come
back right down to that stacked buying
and balance level you had another stack
binding balance here where the market
just blew right through
but again you know
one of the ways to play stacked buying
imbalances or stack selling imbalances
is for a pullback to that imbalance you
know you just sit in there with a bid
and you know if you could have
thrown in a bid you know in that
imbalance i don't know if you would have
got it here
but you know maybe if you threw it in a
tick or two above which is not uncommon
um you know you could have had a nice
trade but you know that's
that's more of luck if you're buying it
in here um you'd have to come in ahead
and again i don't know if a lot of
people would because your stop would
just be on the other side just as if you
have this stack buying a balance here
you're throwing a bid just above it all
right and you stopped out here and then
you're throwing your bid here okay maybe
you get it
and mark it went up threw in a bit off
this one
right again here's another stack buying
and balance all right and draw a line
here so you can see it
okay this is the top of the imbalance
so again you know if you're throwing in
a tick or two above the imbalance
on that waiting for that pullback
it came right down to that top of that
imbalance here
again if you just one tick above maybe
you would have got it maybe not i don't
know there was only 13 lots traded there
probably you wouldn't have got it
and the market kept going higher he was
a stack selling a balance
but
you know he came back up in there it
sort of stopped then the next bar opened
up
went a little bit higher than traded
down and went sideways so that would
have stopped you out but again so you
know the first thing i would look for
obviously are stacked
imbalances whether stack buying and
balances or stack sauna balances
most software most order flow software
out there
will highlight to you or stacked
buying or selling imbalances okay
now the next thing that i would look for
again these are not in any particular
order
are exhaustion prints now if you use my
software we do highlight them to you
okay so um you know in the software
because i'm shooting this this was a
question that came up in the
user um
training
the exhaustion prints right
so i'm looking for a value of five okay
and you can see here
five or less so it could be five four
three two one
exhaustion print here exhaustion print
here here
here right i don't see any on the upside
so i know
that you know traders are getting tired
selling down in here at one twenty
twelve right even though you know did
trade
uh
120 11 and a half you know every time it
trades down into 12 there's not much
interest
okay it finally got through market went
up again at the bottom of these bars
you're seeing very thin volume now 10
years 10 years is a market that you can
see the volumes that normally trade you
know it's in the thousands
and you're just getting five lots trade
a one lot trade a one lot trade you know
that's something that you want to be
aware of right you could see
um you know it's
just not for today but you know you look
for them you know on
any day you ideally you want to see them
at you know swing highs or swing lows
you know here we are in the middle of a
move down you're seeing exhausted prints
at the top of these bars
again you know this is a market that
trades thousands
at a level and all of a sudden you're
just trading um you know three five you
know here's one at the high of the day
came back made a new high by two ticks
and then had a nice sell-off
you know here's one we're just sort of
hanging around this low trades down here
then finally traders just give up trades
three right then you've got a nice stack
buying and balance in this bar
as well next bar opened up trades right
in there and then you know it's off to
the races so you got stacked imbalances
the first one second one in exhaustion
prints now
the next one is
it's kind of the result you tend to see
them after stacked imbalances but it's
called thin prints right and what that
means is you know in the two-way auction
there's you know the bid there's the
offer okay and when you get
one side being very light volume it
could be zero volume
um you know if the market is five bit at
six nothing trades at on the five bit
everything trades at the six bid i'll
show you the six offer the next thing
you know it's six bid and then it's
seven bit and the market keeps going up
so you can see in here right this would
be an example four lots trade here
right here's six seven again this is a
market where normally you're trading you
know thousands of contracts at a level
and all of a sudden you're just trading
20 trading 17
inside the bar here's 23 right the price
above it you trade 7 000.
right just earlier when you're trading
there the bar previous it traded 669
so 6 700 contracts on the bid 7
900 on the offer
you know that's
what 14 000 15 000 contracts
uh well 14 000 trading right here then
the next bar only manages to trade 23
right as because the market's down and
starts getting bid up but what you have
is you have a very strong buyer coming
in here right they're buying everything
up they turn it bit here
um you know in the very thick markets
like 10 years when you see these thin
prints pay attention to them 33 67.
now again
what's a thin print in one market might
be different than another market 33 and
67 in the 10 years when you're trading 3
you know 4 000 5000 at each price level
is considered a thin print if you're in
say
i don't know say gold right this is gold
on a 10 minute chart
uh let's open this up here so you can
see
you know basically each price level
you're trading double digits you know
anywhere between um you know 20 and and
60 so
you know using
having a thin print level
of
20 you know or 15 is not valid you're
going to want smaller numbers you know
like here you're seeing
three two seven
all right and the market just keeps
roaring up
now
you know euro currencies right
same thing you know there's an
exhaustion print at the high right let's
start looking at these things right you
got an exhaustion print at the high
um you know again if you're looking at
thin prints right you're trading
double-digit numbers right so
looking at you know something in the 20s
or 30s is not is not valid you know what
you want to be looking for is volumes
like this
zero 59206
two
right as the market is going up there's
just not a lot of counter trade taking
place there
um you know there's a stacked buying and
balance but you know again you
stack buying and balance coming out as
you're taking out the new highs which
is what you should see right you should
be seeing stack buying and balances as
you're taking out new highs what i'm
looking for on a 10-minute chart is not
when we're taking out highs or lows um
when we're within the day's range
now lastly the last one i'll talk about
is
sequencing and you know we released the
indicator the order flow sequencing
indicator but if you have my software
it's built in there my users are
familiar with it and what it is
you can see inside the bar there's these
green boxes or
these red boxes right and what that is
that that's order flow that's
bullish in the bar or bearish in the bar
and again it's not just about seeing it
it's about
watching how the order flows occurring
around it and
where to take it okay you know i always
talk about
understanding where you are in trading
in relationship to the days range you
know
um you know are you trading up near the
high or down near the low if you're
trading up near the high i'm always
looking for reasons for potentially
selling right i mean sure the market can
keep going higher but if i'm at the high
of the day
sooner or later you're going to put in
the higher the day and if the market's
if this is the time where the market's
going to react and start selling off
then
you know i want to be prepared and
oftentimes there are there are
signs in the order flow
very fast that you know this market's
about to fall over um let's go to the
e-minis uh
what's the
is the sixth um
tuesday
that we had that sharp sell-off right
after the cash open we rallied up
um
oh it's hard to see it on on the
10-minute chart to put on on the on the
shorter time frame charts you can see
this
coming down coming down coming down let
me just change it to a
five-minute chart just sort of give you
a sort of a different perspective you
know 10-minute charts are
are one thing to look at but when you're
looking at a five minute chart um this
is
ten years okay well while that five
minute e-mini chart is coming up you
know you're
right here on the lows of the day then
you're starting to see the bullish
sequencing coming in in this bar
obviously this bar and the market goes
up um
you know we hit that swing high you got
an exhaustion print there right then you
got the bearish sequencing coming in
here
here's a stacked binding balance okay
that one didn't work you come down you
make the new low
you got the stacked binding balance
right here and you can see how this
market just it's holding that stacked
buying and balance quite nicely you know
people always wonder why does the market
come back to this why do these bars just
come right back to this 09 level well
that's where you had that aggressive
buying earlier right you got your thin
print six
i mean look at these levels it's trading
um you know three and a half thousand
two and a half thousand sixteen hundred
eleven hundred
seven hundred six hundred a thousand
seventeen hundred sixteen hundred fifty
only six trade here
so you know that this market
i'll say skip this level but it moved
through this level pretty quick this is
a ten minute bar had a lot of time to
come in and sort of fill in that volume
and it didn't all right it just kept
going up but you don't see a six in any
of these bars you know you don't see
anything below
what's the lowest here well here's a 27
um
you know 86 25 39
i'm not looking at these edges of those
bars i'm looking inside the bar so six
you know this is
important all right it's telling you
this market's moving fast obviously it's
kind of the result of that stack
of these imbalances
you see how the market came back
obviously e-minis came back here so uh
let's just go back to
uh what day was i saying looking for the
fifth here
but you see right after we put in that
high you're seeing the sequencing
sequencing
and the market just drop nicely
again if you're looking at the 10-minute
chart you're just looking at one bar
here right these two bars are put
together from the high to the low
so
you know again is is it something that's
you know
a 10 minute chart i mean there's certain
things in the order that you can apply
it but
really the
i in my opinion you know the the things
that you want to be looking for would be
stacked imbalances exhaustion prints
thin prints in the normal markets you
know i say normal market hours
um or at least from the european open
until the the u.s close uh you know in
some of the asian markets yeah you can
trade i do
watch the asian markets at night and do
get involved once in a while
um
but you know those got you know for me
it's it's strictly the e-minis um these
markets they they're some of these
markets there's not enough
involvement from the bigger players like
you know when you start looking at
dao or sorry ym the mini dao um in some
of these markets there's just not a lot
of
activity from
outside players outside you know meaning
the institutional players not us retail
traders but um you know sort of the
bigger traders that help move the
markets they're just not there as much
in the asian hours right in asian hours
they're more
focused on what's happening in um
you know in china and japan
so stacked imbalances exhaustion prints
thin prints in
normal market hours
and uh sequencing but again when you get
into thin prints you should understand
the market that you're trading you know
again what it's a considered a thin
print in
uh you know
mini dao
probably might not be a thin print in
another market right because there's
different volumes right when you're
looking at order flow you're considering
the volumes
so if you like this video and want to
see more like it be sure to hit the like
button and more importantly subscribe to
my channel so you'll be notified of new
videos as soon as they're ready so
thanks everyone bye-bye